32 32 s'il vous
plaît toutes les solistes qui
chant il fait partie de la nouvelle
génération des baroqueux ces artistes
passionnés par la musique des 17e et 18e
sièces Raphaël Pichon a découvert
l'univers classique à Versailles il
revient dans la cité royale cette chance
avec pigmon que que Laurent et ses
équipes nous fassent extrêmement
confiance et qu'on puisse développer
tout un tas de projets parfois même des
projets un peu inouï et inédit qu'on
fait un peu surmesure pour ici comme
l'ont été ces
funérailles de Louis XIV la saison
passée l'une des spécialités des
baroqueux allit à la recherche à la
redécouverte de partitions d'œuvres
oubliées que l'ensemble pigmalion qui
fête ses 10 ans cette année aime
interprét le goût pour pour la
redécouverte parfois on n'est pas du
tout les premiers à à à redécouvrir mais
en tout cas euh parce que un grand grand
travail a déjà été fait par par les
générations au-dessus de nous mais
effectivement il reste quand même malgré
tout encore quelques quelques zones
d'ombre je dirais et puis peut-être
aussi de bousculer certaines idées
reçues pour cette nouvelle saison il
propose à nouveau orpéo de Luigi Ross il
jouit seulement à deux reprises à
Versailles et consacrer meilleur
spectacle lyrique de l'année moi ce qui
m'intéresse surtout c'est c'est j'espère
le choc que peuvent que pourront
ressentir les personnes qui pas entendu
face à cette partition parce que c'est
de la musique extraordinaire et je pèse
mes mots vraiment qui une œuvre que je
trouve quand on l'entend devrait avoir
sa place j'espère aura un jour sa place
au répertoire au même titre au même
titre que leur fait de Glou ou leur fa
de monter verd après stravagan d'amore
Raphaël Pichon et l'ensemble pigmalion
seront de retour sur la scène de l'Opéra
royale le 9 novembre ils présenteront
Zoroastre de Jean-Philippe Ramo